class acdl drivers we are hiring for
regional positions in your area and we
are giving away the largest sign-on
bonus that we've ever given ten thousand
dollars that's right ten thousand
dollars this might seem extreme but
offers like these are becoming more
common for truck driving jobs that's
because amid a global supply chain
crunch with mounting shipping delays the
us trucking industry needs drivers and
it needs them now for truck drivers
demand is high people are desperate to
to get them because there's this big
volume of stuff that needs to get moved
and trucks move about 70 percent maybe a
bit more of the freight in the u.s
current estimates from the american
trucking associations show there is a
shortage of 80 000 truck drivers on the
road which is a 30 increase from 2019
and a record high for the industry if
the trend continues that number could
grow to 160 000 by 2028 the market that
we're in today is
requiring and i think will continue to
require for a period of time very
strategic moves relative to incentives
and to ways that we are attracting and
retaining drivers night swift
transportation the largest truckload
carrier in north america is among the
companies that have boosted pay to try
to attract drivers the company said its
driving school graduates are on track to
earn more than 60 thousand dollars a
year in their first year after training
and as high as a hundred thousand in
some markets that's more than double the
median pay for truck drivers in the us
earned in 2020. and industry-wide the
average weekly earnings for long-haul
truckload drivers are up more than 25
percent since the beginning of 2019.
it's always a little bit of a challenge
hiring drivers particularly for these
long distance trucking jobs where people
are away from home the conditions can be
kind of grueling one incentive some
trucking companies are offering to
attract new drivers
sign on bonuses
84 of truck driver jobs on employment
marketplace zip recruiter have included
some mention of bonus this year there's
always a market effect where if you need
people you start to pay more you offer
bonuses you do board you also have to
get them trained up and that can take
some time if you're if you're trying to
recruit people who weren't in the
industry before one of the biggest us
trucking companies yellow corporation
said they have hosted at least 145
recruiting events this year and
enrollment numbers at its driver
academies are up 500 percent compared
with pre-pandemic numbers night swift
plans to more than double its number of
company training locations to meet the
increased demand for drivers i think
it's fair to say that there is more
pressure today than we've seen in a long
time perhaps ever even as we think
through the driver dynamic the pandemic
had impact in the driver's sourcing
the trucking industry's challenges have
come into focus recently as a crush of
imports overwhelms ports and u.s
retailers struggled to restock
inventories that emptied out during the
pandemic but the driver shortage is not
new depending on who you talk to in the
trucking sector there's been a driver
shortage for something like two or three
decades it does have a lot of churn
there's a lot of turnover it's a tough
job and it can pay fairly well for blue
collar work but you put in a lot of
hours the american trucking associations
say there is a 90 annual turnover rate
at large truckload carriers and the
average age of drivers is 47.
according to the labor department women
account for less than eight percent of
truck drivers in the u.s and the
industry skews predominantly white the
trucking industry has been concerned for
a while they really want to get younger
people in the pipeline they want to get
more women they want to try and get
other people excited about these driving
jobs but it's been a little bit of an
uphill battle from a driver's sourcing
perspective we're seeing recovery in
that relative to schools and training
programs and those kind of things but
they're just there's just a gap to fill
even with these new incentives and an
uptick in driver training enrollment
there could still be a long road ahead
to remedying the truck driver shortage
and unclogging the supply chain gridlock
the thing to remember is that we are
still in the middle of a global pandemic
so a lot of factors in the supply chain
rest on what's happening in a factory
overseas or how much capacity there is
on a ship but you just sort of have to
take it as it comes and and hope that
the different kinks in the chain unkink
themselves
[Music]
you